minecraft is all about collecting  resources and building whatever your  heart desires but wouldn't it be nice to  have some of those goodies just  delivered to you well that's exactly  what mojang is doing with mine chest a  new loot subscription service for thirty  bucks a month plus taxes and seven  dollars shipping and handling you can  get new t-shirts toys and collectibles  each month the first mind chest ships in  May but anyone who orders by the end of  februari gets a special beta version we  all know what it will include but the  description says it will quote explore  the beginnings of Minecraft we probably  won't find out what's inside until the  first round of Luke gets delivered my  chest is currently available in the US  only but mojang is working to bring the  service to the rest of the world you can  sign up at the official website and for  all the minecraft news you're already in  the right place